let's talk about a few things at our
current event which is something a lot
of people are interested in so your
fight ends
um
with uh uh cyril and you win the fight
and one of the biggest controversies was
hey
where is dana to put the belt on and not
to put the belt on he's addressed it
you've addressed it but i'm curious to
know what your
thoughts are going to be at this point
dana comes out and says listen i
actually walked out of the arena right
after the co-main event because there
was stuff going on that i was dealing
with and i can see that happening when
you're running a business this is a big
fight though that you were having for
anybody to think that i was showing any
type of disrespect towards francis i saw
francis all week you idiots i shook his
hand i said hi to him i was out there
for stare downs the whole thing so for
anybody to think that there was some
type of disrespect towards francis i
wasn't out there for michael bisping
versus luke rockhold's fight either
because i was dealing with some stuff i
sprinted from back i didn't even have my
jacket on i only had my shirt on to go
and put the belt on bisping but i
couldn't make it out there to put the
belt on francis so at this point
everyone said what they've said
how did you feel afterwards when he
wasn't there did you guys have a
follow-up conversation together
personally
i didn't care
i made my statement that night
i was happy
you know
and um
[Music]
i don't know
if that's true or not
i don't care
what i do know is like i made my
statement it wasn't about the bad it
wasn't around about
dinner wrapping the belt around me or
the press conference or anybody by the
way
mick manner which is the for me is a
great guy wrap the belt
around my waist and uh that would be a
problem for me
maybe he has a um
a situation going on
i have no problem with me grabbing the
belt around my waist you know i'm very
cool and very happy
with me
doesn't mean
anything
things was great maybe people are having
this speculation because of our
situation
the state of our situation
but it's possible that
something happened you know
that he was out for some business
but um
i don't care
i mean
you can ask people for so much but the
only thing that you can the biggest
respect that you're gonna have is you
respecting yourself standing by
what you believe
and then making your point and that's
what i did that night so whatever was
around it i didn't care if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]